I was like four years old and all my
earliest memories of of him because he
was terrifying he was in violent
alcoholic bipolar but not diagnosed
until we were older uh and I remember we
walk into his grandma's uh place we're
staying with my great grandma for the
weekend on his side and I walk in and
I'm like four and I'm all excited to see
her she hated me and I didn't you know
when an adult hates you and you don't
clock it because you're like what an
insane thing to hate a four-year-old and
also you're confused because like am I
feeling is this am I yeah before you
fully have that yeah awareness of like
oh people cannot like you but we walk in
she's immediately shitty part of it is
I'm half Indian and like this is a part
of it
she's 100 racist and she was uh she was
the Honeydew with Ryan